hi everyone i'm andy gupmans general
manager and vp of engineering for
databases of google cloud
thank you for joining us for google
cloud next we have some exciting product
announcements to share with you in the
session
digital innovators are disrupting
traditional industries in new ways
because of their ability to use data and
software to deliver new
digital customer experiences
customers expect personalized and
seamless experiences across their
devices in all places and at all times
to deliver these next generation digital
experiences developers need to be
empowered to build apps faster by
leveraging fully managed databases
use their existing skills and
investments and build their apps for
success with databases that were
designed to power the most demanding
workloads in the world
we offer best-in-class databases for
always-on applications with global reach
and unlimited scale
google cloud is committed to open source
and open standards we offer managed
services that are fully compatible with
the most popular open source engines
such as mysql postgres and redis
we manage the complexity of running your
database so that they are simple to use
and operate and make app development
faster and easier for you
leading organizations in all regions and
industries have placed their trust in
our databases and our databases remain
one of the fastest growing segments of
google cloud
in the newly published gardner 2021
scorecard for operational databases
google cloud received an overall score
of 90 out of 100 which is higher than
the score of the largest alternative
cloud provider
google cloud met 100
of the required criteria outlined by by
gardner
also
gartner predicts that 75
of databases will be deployed or
migrated to a cloud platform by next
year
imagine 40 years of databases placed on
premises being superseded by cloud
databases in such a short duration it's
amazing
our customers journey to undergo
data-driven transformation typically
involves three steps
the first step migrate
is there to help customers move existing
applications and databases to the cloud
frequently on a tight timeline
customers need a fast-track approach to
lift and shift what they're running
today to the cloud
this as-is migration already adds
tremendous value
even if it doesn't provide the full
benefits of cloud native capabilities
once migrated many of our customers seek
to modernize their database environments
by transitioning up expensive legacy
databases and onto open source databases
for customers looking to build next-gen
applications entirely in the cloud
they're in the transform phase
this is about unlocking new new
possibilities and competitive
differentiation
it's about delivering new
transformational customer experiences
and innovative business models
for your existing databases that you
need to easily migrate to a fully
managed cloud service we offer cloud sql
with full compatibility for mysql
postgres and sql server it is one of the
fastest growing large services in google
cloud
cloud sql offers easy integration with
existing apps and google cloud services
like google kubernetes engine and
bigquery
more than 650
000 gke pods securely connect to cloud
sql
and bigquery users query over
125 petabytes of data in cloud sql on
average in a month using our federated
querying capabilities
we've invested heavily in improving
cloud sql and making it enterprise ready
for your demanding workloads
in the past 12 months we have introduced
capabilities such as cross region
replicas point in time recovery customer
managed encryption keys vpc service
controls and iem support
we have significantly improved the
maintenance experience for customers and
given the maintenance controls cloud sql
maintenance is on average 80 percent
shorter than it was 12 months ago
and maintenance for mysql and postgres
is now shorter than that of competing
offerings from other cloud providers
based on figures published in online
documentation as of august 2021
earlier this year we launched
industry-leading observability with
cloud sql insights for postgres
it empowers developers to address
database performance issues themselves
at no additional cost
this has become one of the fastest
adopted new capabilities in cloud sql
and we look forward to delivering
equivalent functionality across more
database engines
in addition we recently introduced cloud
sql cost cost recommenders with active
assist that empowers developers to
better manage costs
we have made migrations to cloud sql
easier and faster with the database
migration service
this offers a simple experience with
minimal downtime for reliable and
predictable migrations to cloud sql
it is serverless
secure
and offered at no additional charge
more than 85 percent of all migrations
are underway in under an hour and a
majority of customers are migrating
databases from other clouds
database migration service currently
supports mysql and postgres databases
with support for sql server migrations
coming soon
for customers bringing oracle workloads
to google cloud we offer our bare metal
solution for oracle that allows you to
run oracle databases the same way you do
it on premises but cost effectively and
with less than two milliseconds latency
to all of your gcp services
bare metal solution enables you to
continue using your existing oracle
technologies
such as rack
data guard and rmn
for workloads that require microsecond
latency we offer memory store
memory store is fully compatible with
redis and memcache and offers an easy
migration destination for your redis and
memcache workloads
memory store is a scalable secure
highly available in memory service that
is used by 90
of the top 100 cloud customers
we recently announced a preview of data
stream a serverless change data capture
and replication service
with datastream you can easily and
seamlessly deliver change data streams
from your oracle and mysql databases
into google cloud services such as
bigquery cloud sql google cloud storage
and spanner
the serverless architecture of
datastream transparently scales up or
down as data volumes shift in real time
now let's discuss our transformative
databases and how they can help you
transform your business models and the
digital experiences for your users
today your business critical
applications may need to serve millions
of users across the globe and process
data volumes that are an order of
magnitude higher than just a few years
ago
new always-on business models require
these applications to be reliable
secure and continuously available
your applications need to scale
seamlessly and sustain high performance
even during unexpected spikes in demand
we give you access to the same databases
that power the most demanding google
applications like search youtube gmail
maps and payments
google had to invent these databases
because traditional databases were not
designed to handle these demands for
scale availability and performance
we offer not one but three such
transformative databases
spanner bigtable and firestore
all three of them have a common set of
highly differentiated core attributes
like industry leading five nines
availability slas
no maintenance downtime
unlimited scale
automatic sharding
zero touch global replication
automatic failover
superior price performance and enhanced
security and compliance
spanner is our fully managed relational
database that offers the familiarity and
developer experience of a relational
database and the scalability of a nosql
database
spanner enables unlimited scale so you
can easily accommodate future growth
without painful re-architecting adjust
your capacity on the fly and pay for
only what you use
it allows you to deliver high
performance transactions with strong
consistency across regions and
continents
so you can simplify operations and
place data close to your users
our enterprise customers in financial
services gaming retail technology and
many other industries run some of the
most demanding operational workloads on
spanner
with spanner you can spend less time
worrying about how to scale your
database and instead focus on scaling
your business
as wonderful and unique as spanner is it
wasn't the most accessible database for
developers
we wanted developers to be able to start
small with spanner so they could design
their applications for success from the
get-go
to this end we recently introduced more
granular instant sizing for spanner to
democratize access to it
with more granular instant sizing you
can start at one tenth the cost of
regular instances equating to
approximately 65 dollars per month
this means you can start small
and easily scale your spanner instance
as your workload grows with no downtime
developers love the scale and
availability of spanner but they wanted
to take advantage of spanner using their
familiar open tools and their existing
skill set
therefore to continue this theme of
democratizing access to spanner we're
excited to announce the preview of a
postgres interface for spanner starting
today
this empowers developers to take
advantage of google's transformative
relational database using standard tools
and skills from the popular postgres
ecosystem
this interface combines the power and
reliability of spanner with the
familiarity and portability of postgres
to enhance flexibility
by providing a postgres interface we're
democratizing access to spanner for
millions of developers and isvs
starting today you can create spanner
databases that use postgresql dialect
and connect with its open wire protocol
this interface supports spanner's rich
feature set using most popular postgres
data types and sql features
postgres interface for spanner is
available at no additional charge
what this means is that for your
postgres workloads we offer you not one
but two fully managed services
for maximum compatibility with open
source postgres and for the easiest lift
and shift migrations you have cloud sql
for postgres
for your most demanding workloads where
you need unlimited scale and five lines
availability slas we offer spanner with
its new postgres interface that allows
you to leverage your skills and
investments in the postgres ecosystem
we're super excited about our rich
postgres offerings
now for apps that require consistent
single digit millisecond latencies and
need to support millions of requests per
second we offer bigtable
bigtable is our fully managed nosql
database for large operational and
analytical workloads and it's hbase
compatible
bigtable is uniquely capable of powering
use cases like personalization at scale
and fraud detection
we're excited to share that auto scaling
is coming soon to bigtable
this will allow bigtable to
automatically add or remove capacity in
response to changing demands of your
workloads so you only pay for the
capacity you need
we talked about the importance of the
velocity of your application iteration
for rapid app development we offer
firestore our fully managed scalable
serverless document database
firestore is beloved by developers
because of its ability to serve both as
a document database
and a backend as a service
firestore enables offline support with
real-time synchronization
an example of how much developers love
firestore is that firestore has more
than 250 000 monthly active developers
and firestore apps power more than
750 million monthly active users
using firebase authentication
not only is firestore extremely
developer friendly
but we're also focusing on making
firestore more enterprise friendly
we're introducing a number of
enhancements to firestore for greater
enterprise readiness
with that i'd like to introduce one of
our most innovative customers who has
successfully accomplished a data-driven
cloud transformation
it is my pleasure to invite kumar menon
svp of data fabric and decision science
technology at equifax
kumar thank you for joining us today we
would love to hear about equifax's
innovation that you and your team have
been driving in partnership with us
thank you randy
i wanted to start off by
giving you some background on equifax
and the transformation
we are under
echo facts is a leading data analytics
and technology company and it's one of
the three biggest credit trading
agencies we are present in 24 countries
worldwide
in 2018 we embarked on a massive
company-wide transformation to modernize
our technology this was a result of
an unfortunate breach incident in 2017
which brought the global spotlight onto
our company
due to the oversight that was placed on
us and the need for us to ensure we are
good custodians of the high fidelity
data we have
we realized that patching and modifying
our legacy systems would not be a
sustainable solution
we made the bold decision to adopt a
cloud first strategy and rewrite all of
our data platforms and associated
applications leveraging a cloud-native
architecture
our legacy systems were operated in
silos which made it difficult to
effectively innovate and monetize our
differentiated data assets
through
new multi-data products
so we also took this as an opportunity
to reorganize our data under a common
enterprise domain model
onto a single global data fabric with
the security and automated governance
baked into the architecture
the goal was to make it easier for our
data and analytics and product teams to
innovate and deliver new products faster
thus helping our customers and consumers
make better decisions
here's what our end-to-end data flow
looks like
the data fabric is at the heart of the
equifax value chain
if you look at this illustration from
left to right the data fabric helps us
ingest
different domains of data we bring into
our ecosystem in a consistent reliable
highly performant governed compliant and
secure manner so that our product data
analytics and business teams can
leverage the synergies of all the data
assets to innovate and deliver products
that our customers need
in short we want
global data at our fingertips echo fax
cloud will enable
our product innovation growth and
competitiveness
the data fabric platform is pivotal to
the equifax business model going forward
why is the equifax data fabric a game
changer let me give you a few examples
equifax has moved from 80 plus data
silos enabling multiple sources of data
to be standardized and organized into a
seamless data fabric with logical
separation and governing rules
the structure drastically simplifies our
architecture and gives equifax the
ability to act quickly
to address customer regulatory and
security needs
we will achieve bolt-on mergers and
acquisitions
with better and faster integrations than
ever before accelerating our
growth tremendously
now let's look at a more technical view
of the data fabric and see how we have
leveraged gcp managed database services
to deliver our analytics and operational
workloads let me break those down for
you from top to bottom
the data fabric services shown here help
curate the raw data we collect across
the various domains such as credit
employment wealth utilities etc to name
a few
we then key and link the data which is a
form of entity resolution process that
helps us identify
a single unique instance of an entity
for example a unique consumer identity
across all the domains of data we
correct
this data is then made available for
predictive models and real-time
decisioning as a set of purpose-specific
views with the regulatory rules applied
thus ensuring permissible use
this low latency high value ecosystem
leverages cloud bigtable
as the core data store and the pipelines
are built in cloud dataflow
the cloud bigtable scalable architecture
and its support for customer managed
encryption keys help us provide a
resilient reliable and secure data
platform to support highly stringent
millisecond slas that our customers
demand from us
the data fabric is a tightly coupled
with our ignite
and our analytic services which is used
by our data scientists for feature
engineering and building predictive
models which can be deployed into our
decisioning systems
facilitating a full ammo ops ecosystem
the data lake that powers ignite is
built on bigquery
our enterprise catalog services are
built on cloud sql this is what you see
in the middle of this picture
it houses all of the metadata for our
data features and models plus the rules
that are applied that are applied on our
data
this provides the auditability and the
automated governance capability
this design gives qfx a leading position
as a data analytics and technology
company in a highly regulated space
finally i wanted to leave you with some
metrics of where we would be before
when we were finally migrating onto this
platform
we are looking at 75 plus data fabric
services deployed in seven regions
supporting the 24 countries we operate
in
we would have ton plus billions of
observations keyed
using almost 90 plus thousand
clicking and linking rules enabling us
to manage 800 plus million unique
identities globally
we are well into our journey with
significant production traffic coming
soon we have an aggressive plan to grow
the company via acquisitions and
organically
the partnership we've had with google
through this entire journey has been
great both our engineering teams have
been able to collaborate closely to
achieve these capabilities
and this seamless access to the product
and product engineering teams at google
you know have been
key we have invested in a long-term
relationship with google
and look forward to a symbiotic
partnership
thank you for having me and hope you
guys found this presentation useful
kumar thank you for sharing your story
of data-driven cloud transformation it's
truly inspiring
we look forward to our ongoing
partnership with you and equifax
at heart
google is a data company when it comes
to managing data
we had to solve some of the most
difficult problems
we reimagined databases
and invented spanner
a database that gives you the best of
relational and non-relational databases
our databases benefit from disaggregated
compute and storage and our privately
owned global network to improve
performance
scalability
security and availability
what all this means is that when you
adopt our cloud databases you
immediately benefit from our
long-standing culture of engineering
excellence and innovation
there is a lot more exciting content
waiting for you in the upcoming sessions
i invite you to join these sessions to
learn more about google cloud databases
and i would like to thank you for
joining us at google cloud next
we hope to partner with you to
accelerate your data-driven business
transformation
thank you